i want first
response to the ons helicopter pirates
of the caribbean on stranger tides was
not only expensive but dangerous
adding to the expense was over a
thousand shots of cgi there was so much
to do they had 10 different vfx
companies working at the same time let's
dive into the behind the scenes and find
out what went into the making of on
stranger tides
working with some of the greatest actors
in the world is terribly exciting
director rob marshall preferred shooting
on location as much as possible and this
decision almost cost him his life while
shooting in the jungles of hawaii
marshall got a real taste of the
mercilessness of the wild
mid-conversation with johnny depp and
penelope cruz he slipped while standing
on a cliff thanks to his quick reflexes
he managed to grab a vine just before
taking a dive this didn't deter him
though as he believes you are having an
adventure while you are making one the
team agreed it was better to recreate
the set in studio not just because of
this but because of the dangers
presented by the surf
actress penelope cruz was pregnant
during the filming
there she was you know fencing and
fighting and
amazing at pregnancy she had two months
of training leading up to filming but
ultimately couldn't do everything she
had to make choices for the safety of
her and her future child and so her
sister monica was brought in to be her
double for some of the scenes monica is
an actress and dancer in spain and is
very good with swords a perfect choice
to fill in for some of the fight scenes
but also to hide that baby bump
and then i did
a lot of it but i always say nothing
nothing dangerous one of the many
reasons on stranger tides was so
expensive to film comes down to the
props that were designed for the movie
more than a dozen washed-up mermaids
each in different stages of decay were
created over the course of seven weeks
one incredibly detailed mermaid was
casted of silicone to give it a whale
blubbery texture for when barbosa kicks
it
mermaid
give up this madness now
it's kind of a tragedy how much of it is
covered with sand in the film because
the detail in the design is absolutely
incredible
did everyone see that because i will not
be doing it again pirates of the
caribbean on stranger tides is the most
expensive movie ever made holding the
record even 10 years later with a budget
of roughly
379 million it came in at well over 400
million that makes it more expensive
than the avengers films and avatar
johnny depp is one of the reasons for
the expensive budget he made a whopping
55 million for the film and admits he
was overpaid
too much
but says he's keeping the money because
it isn't for him it's for his kids
movies filmed at sea are often the most
expensive which is why all of the
pirates of the caribbean movies cost so
much we had beautiful actresses playing
the mermaids mermaids were a huge part
of on stranger tides and director rob
marshall was very specific about how he
wanted them to look while disney gave
the team the go-ahead to make them look
super scary marshall decided to dial
that back and still keep the beautiful
qualities about the actresses in an
attempt to create never-before-seen
mermaids the team landed on a design
that included jellyfish-like tendrils a
lot of references were used from sea
life to human skin they even bought some
fish at the fish market for their
research
i'm jack sparrow the one and only
and i am in london
this film is the first in the series to
be shot entirely in 3d a choice by
director rob marshall who says the crew
felt like pioneers we were taking 3d
equipment into these remote locations
where you have the possibility of one of
two cameras breaking which they did more
than once that's an entrance
filming in 3d in temperamental
environments like jungles caves
waterfalls ships and cliffs can really
add to the number of problems you run
into marshall believes that to use 3d
you have to be telling a story in a
world that people are going to want to
enter so he avoided green screens as
much as possible putting actual ships in
tiny bottles is the kind of ingenuity
we've come to expect from the franchise
the team designed the ships to look like
they did when they were first captured
stormy cg water special lighting
lightning and more was added to make the
bottle containing the black pearl look
as if it had been captured in a storm
the team even went so far as to include
a shot of jack the monkey we named the
monkey jack
while one of the shots was the real
capuchin other shots were just cg
let's take everybody up thank you
and oh filming a movie about pirates
you're going to run into a lot of
mishaps with swords our favorite being
between kevin mcnally and johnny depp
sorry my sword nearly went up johnny's
nose which wouldn't be good
while it sounds innocent enough these
mistakes can often be quite dangerous
but luckily no one was hurt and we got
great bloopers like depp trying again
and again and again to take cruz's hat
off with his sword i think this takes
going very well don't you
[Laughter]
in order for penelope cruz to do such a
perfect imitation of depp's character
the whole thing was staged like dance
choreography to keep her identity a
secret involved an intricate costume
carefully planned shots low lighting and
a ton of cg
while the two of them battle it out on
the rafters they're strung up in
complicated rigs to remove all the wires
the editors replaced the roof and cg and
created the cg barrels you can see in
the background many girls dream of being
a mermaid and the women casted to play
them in on stranger tides were thrilled
to be there being evil an evil mermaid
but it's gonna be awesome actual olympic
athletes were hired for some of the
sequences while actors took on the
speaking parts and the stunt doubles
took on some of the more dangerous work
there'll be mermaids upon us within the
hour you mark my words animals have to
go through months of training to perform
simple tasks but training is always fun
when there's food around for chiquita
the monkey a lot of time grapes bananas
and pudding goes into training while the
pig's goal was simple to escape the
clutches of kevin mcnally in a game of
tug-of-war pigs they never work with
them
teaching an animal to escape sounds like
a pretty backwards pet trick to us it's
160 pounds of very low good traction the
scene where queen anne's revenge is
chasing the mermaids is pretty much all
done with cg the ship the fire the water
and the mermaids are not real that
leaves us wondering what is funny enough
queen anne's revenge is the first ship
in the series that's based on an actual
pirate ship
so at least we know one thing is real
you can't have your cake and eat it too
unless of course your captain jack
sparrow an incredibly complicated
sequence is played out in the film when
jack goes after a cream puff that gets
stuck to a chandelier unfortunately for
johnny depp it's just cg
the chandelier however was real and was
controlled by giant pulleys and motors
that had to support the weight of depp
the sequence where queen anne's revenge
comes to life and fights back against
the crew had incredibly intricate
choreography in place
my favorite part of the day hanging on a
line for hours
a lot had to come together in order for
this scene to work from pyrotechnics to
sword fights and half the cast fighting
back against magical ropes some of which
were cgi it made for quite the shot
filming in the port of los angeles on
the hms providence was an exciting
adventure for the cast and crew because
it was actually fully functional as a
ship and required a sailing crew a fully
cg version of the ship was also designed
for when the mermaids tear it apart what
we're wondering is how much of the cast
got seasick while filming on the ship
with a large scale production
world-renowned actors and some of the
most innovative equipment in the film
industry it's clear why on stranger
tides blew every other movie out of the
water with its crazy high budget
but did anyone think the cost of
immortality would come cheap
when asked the cast said they would be
hesitant to drink from the fountain of
youth would you let us know in the
comments